you're watching spike coming up on this
week's show right for change innovations
in the wine world smart art of how
synthetic DNA technology can scuff
forgeries and it's all-out war in our
games review hello and welcome to swipe
this week we're at an art framing studio
we're here to meet the British company
fighting art forgery using synthetic DNA
technology more on that in a moment but
first from fine art to fine wine Chris
has spent this week looking at how
technology is changing one of the
world's oldest industries well that's
the excuse you gave us anyway virtual
reality isn't something you'd normally
associate with wine but this be our
vineyard complete with its own bird
noises aims to give the unique spin on
blind tasting as my wine is poured on
screen hints give various flavor
profiles the idea is that you have to
use what you've learned to match the
digital drinks up to the real thing what
do you think so that one tastes quite
citrusy it's all a bit of fun but how
does it compare to being out on the
country estates of France Italy or Spain
it's not a matter of replacing going to
a vineyard in a different country it's
more of trying to create a full
experience on a wine-tasting
within where you are at that moment and
with the music you've got there's a lot
of other tech making its way into the
wine industry for those who prefer their
wine decanted this smart device aims to
speed up the process it draws in air
from outside and pumps it into the wine
meaning an our and traditional decanting
time only takes a minute
it even links to your smartphone working
out the best duration based on the label
and then sending you a notification when
it's ready I often hear the argument
that you know part of the joy of wine is
is seeing it evolve during the course of
an evening if you are a wine connoisseur
you know how that wine is going to
develop then you know fair enough you
can reserve that experience for yourself
however most wine consumers even
consumers of fine wine we just want to
enjoy a perfect glass of wine and that's
what we are striving to deliver there's
clearly a demand for these kind of
products this smart wine bottle smashed
its crowdfunding record earlier this
year it keeps the contents fresh for up
to a month by stopping oxygen seeping in
and even has a touchscreen that suggests
food pairings but some say too much
technology dilutes the wine drinking
experience I think technology in the
wine industry is needed but I do think
that actually wine is quite a
complicated subject so the more
technology that we have actually in some
cases it makes it more complex for a
consumer you know sometimes you just
won't mind it'd be wine it's got to be
simply you got a taste you gotta love it
I think sometimes these things cloud
what's in the actual bottle itself wine
is more popular now than ever with 60%
of UK adults saying it's their favorite
alcoholic drink all this gadgetry might
not be to everyone's tastes wine B has a
herbaceous finish but as the market
grows it's likely we'll see more ideas
pouring in Chris Craig and Sky News stay
with us still to come I'll be getting a
close-up look at some synthetic DNA
technology being used for event art
forgeries but before then here's a
roundup of some of this week's other
techniques the US Navy is launching a
new type of weapon literally these
drones are fired into the air and attack
in swarms making them hard to target
with standard anti-aircraft defences the
aptly named locust project is still in
its test phase but experts think it
could be the future of warfare Mount
Everest southern climbing route has been
filmed in 360 for the first time it
means you can get a full view from the
highest points on earth without
Swiss mountaineering equipment company
Mamet sports group are behind the
project they say the idea is to bring
the concept of Google Streetview to the
most beautiful mountains on the planet
the gadget that it's claimed can turn
any surface into a remote control has
smashed its crowdfunding target taking
in more than half a million dollars in
just a week no key attaches to walls
doors and furniture and then syncs up to
your home devices so you can turn off
your telly switch off your alarm or set
your coffee machine just by knocking
stick around for our games review where
we return to the world of Spira
blitzball anyone now let's get back to
why we're at this London framing studio
come on over and meet Laurence Merritt
he's the CEO of a company developing
technology to prevent art forgery tell
us about it sure it's a unique time that
artists typically attach to the back of
their work and we're pretending this is
the back of a page we're pretending that
this is the back of a painting is one
that we prepared earlier and why is it
special it has about 20 different
security features on it which makes it
impossible to copy fake off or what kind
of security features are in there well
an example of one of the security
features is a synthetic DNA that we've
made in a lab in Cambridge
what's a synthetic DNA it's a man-made
deer no it's not a human it's nobody's
DNA it's it's it's a nobody's DNA -
man-made DNA it's how it has about half
a billion particles and only we have the
key to the code of that DNA how easy is
it to get these on the back of painting
it's really simple we have an applicator
or a stamp so every artist has their own
stamp their own applicator it takes
about five seconds to apply they put
this onto the back of their work
wherever they want to stamp it they
press this down the unique pattern on
that against the unique pattern of the
stencil creates a unique mark there they
then peel this back to reveal the paper
label housing the DNA they flap this
down and the work is tagged now here's
why whenever we look at new technology
we like to get the view of other
industry experts I'm gonna call in James
Ratcliffe from the Art Loss Register
he's been listening patiently from
behind our cameraman Andy James thanks
for joining us now you're an expert in
dealing with stolen artwork and forged
artwork what do you think of this tag
smart technology I think it's a
fantastic
living contemporary artists to protect
their work it's a very difficult area
for the art market to face the question
of authenticity and anything that can be
produced that helps to demonstrate to
buyers that what they are requiring is
the real thing is a good thing yeah what
is the current industry standard way of
authenticating artwork unfortunately
there is no standard it's typically the
artist signing the work a signature
signature which I could just fake or
anyone who doesn't know anybody could
just fake you anything you don't like
about this um the question mark with all
of these systems is the question of how
easy it is to actually check the mark or
the tag against some kind of database
and it seems people a synthetic DNA
they're going to panic but from
everything that Lawrence has said it
sounds like it's a relatively
straightforward system so that will help
it in the in the market
however in different art form now here's
Luke with this week's games review total
war Warhammer brings together two
long-standing British institutions the
first is Games Workshop's Warhammer
series of miniature figures and the
second is creative Assembly's Total War
series of games previously the total war
games have been strategy games that have
focused on history so whether it's the
Shogun era of Japan Rome or the medieval
era this is the first one to actually
leave history behind and go into the
realms of fantasy and it's made people
ask why on earth this has never happened
before there's two parts of the game the
first is an overall map where you
basically take control of an army and
get to move them around and try and
build up settlements and the second is
where you face off against your foes on
the battlefield itself we need to gather
the two different series is inspired
before some of the older games suffered
from too many of the different factions
feeling the same but now when you take
control of the humans you have either
Gryphon riders and majors of your the
dwarves you get to take control of big
big artillery and mechanical creations
if you opt goes the or greenskins then
you constantly have to keep
hacking because if you fail to do so
they start to in fight and your army
collapses in itself like a dying star
and if you choose to be the vampires
then you need to plan quite far ahead
because they need to spread corruption
wherever they go lest they burn to dust
in the light of the Sun it's a very very
new take on the game and hopefully a
taste of things to come conquer this
world Fire Emblem fates is the latest
installment in a series that's been
going for 26 years it comes in two
different varieties Fire Emblem conquest
is for series veterans who've played a
bit before and Fire Emblem birthright is
for newcomers to the franchise it's
basically a tactical RPG so what you're
doing is you're selecting your
characters from a range of classes and
you're building a team moving them
around and basically trying to complete
the campaign but another side of the
game is the relationship between the
characters you have a hub called my
castle that you can decorate as you
please and build lots of different
buildings and focus on really building
the relationships between the members of
your squad the reason you want to do
this is because if they're of the
opposite gender romance can blossom
between them and they can actually have
offspring that inherit the best
abilities of both parents if you haven't
tried Fire Emblem yet this is the game
to get involved with especially the
birthright addition it's got the best
graphics the best writing and the story
is incredibly enjoyable
by fancy 10 and final fancy tend to were
originally released back on the ps2 way
back at the turn of the millennium but
now they've been re-released in HD and
this week they are coming to PC
specifically steam if you haven't played
the game although Final Fantasy has
fallen on hard times in recent years
these are from the Golden Age of Final
Fantasy Final Fantasy 10 is one of the
first truly 3d games in the series still
has the turn-based battles still has the
random battles and still has airship
exploration it's an incredibly deep an
interesting game and the storyline
although some of the dialogue has aged
quite poorly is still very enjoyable 10
- isn't quite as good it's more
lighthearted and set just slightly after
the events of the first game however it
is still quite unique and the real-time
battles in this marked a turning point
for series and so it's definitely worth
giving a shot but the real reason you
want to get involved in these games is
because of the world that it's formed
the world of Spira is unparalleled by
any other world in any other Final
Fantasy game whether it's the religious
zealots that are trying to tell you that
everything bad that's happening is your
fault or the tropical beachside huts
that the peasantry live in it's
incredibly varied incredibly beautiful
and a world that if you haven't explored
yet you really need
well that's it for this week take a look
at Sky News on mobile tablet catch up
sky cute and snapchat for the latest
tech stories throughout the week and
I'll see you again next time bye bye